welcome back now it is August and some
people are very upset about Billboards
apparently there's something that
happens in August only fans model Eliza
Rose Watson paid for these giant posters
advertising her x-rated subscription
content for several sites across London
and New York they've sparked a flurry of
complaints to the UK's advertising
Watchdog which today ruled these
Billboards were not quote overtly sexual
and therefore quite all right to have up
but fewer's campaigners want them banned
arguing that they are normalizing
obscenity so do they have a point more
on this I'm joined by the only fans
model at the center of the route Eliza
Rose Watson and the political
commentator Lauren Chen ladies thank you
very much for joining us
um Eliza first of all you must be
relieved obviously that the Billboards
are staying up
um and
what do you make of the arguments that
this is inappropriate and obscene
well firstly you know I am encouraged
and um pleased that the ASA have ruled
what they've ruled
um I think in general what I make of the
argument is you know it's understandable
in a sense that if someone doing
something new there's a lot of
misconception about what only fans is
and what only fans isn't but
only fans is now a household name it's
no good denying it or pushing it under
the carpet that's what's gonna do damage
you know we need to face it we need to
talk about it we need to
not really focus as much on whether it's
right or wrong whether people should be
doing it or shouldn't be doing it the
fact is they are doing it it's here to
stay we should be focusing on
how we approach it is turning a blind
eye onto it realistic let alone helpful
is Banning it and shaming it just an old
outdated archaic approach which has
never really worked for any societal
issue I think that's
okay interesting the argument does come
up a lot about
um sex work and I only find it somewhere
in the room of that uh anyone who's not
aware I feel like everyone in the world
is aware of what only fans is but it's
when people pay uh content creators for
pretty sexy pictures sexual pictures and
they can be to the very pornographic end
or to the lighter end as well we've just
shown you some pictures there that were
softened for our evening audience Lauren
Chen uh joins us now as well Lauren um
do you buy that argument that we should
be more accepting of this type of work
in society otherwise if we clamp down on
it then it will be worse for a lot of
women
well I think we are plenty accepted
already as a society people are
perfectly able to start only fans
accounts and not only that but become
very financially successful for a slim
minority I think that includes Eliza the
question we were talking about here is
is it appropriate is it okay to
advertise pornography in places where
children can see it you mentioned that
some of these Billboards are right next
to a school and in my opinion the answer
is clearly no and I have to say Eliza
regardless of what the overall Watchdog
ruling is that doesn't mean that you as
a business owner as the person who is
sponsoring these Billboards needs to
keep them up especially the ones that I
think are are under the most controversy
which are the ones near the school you
are able to take them down there are
other ways you can advertise for your
only fans account including I would say
appearing on this show that don't expose
children to this to the concept of
pornography uh you know young girls the
idea of selling their bodies young boys
the idea that women are Commodities
there are other ways to go about this
even if you insist on having an only
fans account that would draw a lot less
fire from parents especially let's give
Eliza a chance to respond to that but
also according to the information I've
got the Billboards uh one of which is
located around 450 meters from a school
which is a fair distance the advertising
standards agency did come back and said
look these Billboards all around New
York and London children walk around
those cities all the time they're going
to see them anyway whether or not the
ruling is correct or not I people have
different opinions on that but Eliza I
mean your chance to respond there are
you advertising pornography widely is it
necessary to do that that's what
Lauren's saying
I think my intention behind the ads was
to do exactly this to start a discussion
that's what my intention was and I think
that's been achieved I will point out
I'm not the first person to put an only
fans logo on an advert there are boxes
and formula one drivers that have the
only fans logo in exactly the same way
on their helmets on their shorts on
their clothing
I think the issue here is people are
putting two and two together with a
woman in the logo I will also say the
only over reference to pornography on my
ad was the graffiti on it and this is
what sparked the Press I got and
ultimately
all the attention this is received the
ad was very clearly designed for adults
I'm a 34 year old woman
all my social media audience is between
the ages of 25 and 35 and 98.8 male
um I will also point out that in the
same vicinity there were alcohol ads on
bus stops presumably where these
children would sit and wait for a bus
home from school the only difference is
that conversations have been had around
alcohol that's the difference and this
is what I'm starting to do here the
other thing is just because there's an
ad with a bottle of beer on it it
doesn't mean a child or a minor could
walk straight into an off license and
buy a beer they'd have to provide ID and
what people don't understand about
owning plans is
same applies there it's actually even
harder even as a Creator when I buy a
new mobile phone I have to physically
call up my network provider provide ID
on credit card in order to even access
the platform and that's even without
subscribing ask I think those are all
really good points to raise you know the
alcohol one as well that Lauren's point
about um
the money aspect of this and the
attention you've received you said your
intention behind it was to raise this
debate of course that has created more
marketing for you and you're going to
receive likely more customers and more
money from this
um was that part of it as well
not really I didn't expect any real
increase in revenue from the Billboards
um as you might know we already
advertise we advertise online
um
I think as well like the point around it
was again to just raise a discussion and
I'd also like to add at this point
the ads do not glorify or glamorize the
use of only fans in any way and I will
make this point about the money
the money can be really good for a small
minority as was mentioned however there
are great sacrifices to be made for
people who do only fans you post a sexy
picture on even Instagram it's there for
your whole life and it's a short-lived
it's a very short-lived career so
these are the kind of things that I
think we need to be talking about Lauren
and it sorry Eliza we're just running
short of time I just want to ask Lauren
final words uh whether you're all
convinced by any of this
well I think it's somewhat silly to say
that the Billboards weren't done at
least in part for increased Revenue
that's the point of billboards and
advertising and I appreciate that Eliza
does bring out of the fact that there
are downsides to only fans but the thing
is that's not what's mentioned on the
spill board on this billboard they're
Simply Her provocative pose a link to
her social media and only fans accounts
and obviously uh children should have
their social media usage monitored by
parents but at the same time I don't
think it's too much to ask for people
who make pornography like Eliza to not
directly Market to Children which is in
part what she's doing there are other
ways she could advertise where you
wouldn't have this fur where they
wouldn't uh be exposed to children but
she is I think specifically trying to
normalize and mainstream she even said
only fans which is not a good thing this
is not a positive for Society for men or
for women
that's interesting oh go on quickly
Eliza because statistically
teenagers are way more likely to be
exposed to sexual imagery on places like
Facebook than they are only fans I
obviously would never purposely have put
this ad next to a school however I think
it's actually you might take it down you
could take it down at any point you're
the one paying for it it doesn't it
doesn't need to be there regardless of
what the agency says you have the
ability to take it down
I did six days after the complaints it
came down so so you agree with that I
guess the complaints in that case
not particularly no I I agree with the
fact I would not like to be directly
directly marketing at children however
it's naive what I was going to say is
it's naive to assume that a teenager
with a mobile phone would not have seen
imagery like this before and this I find
con concerning the fact that people
don't know that or just don't want to
accept it the point of the ads and I
think they've achieved the point is to
start this discussion and maybe raise
we are fresh at our time we have had
that discussion we appreciate both your
points of view